es war genau was roger köppel sagt
dieses chefbeamten chinesisch also sie
haben alle drei irgendwann im verlauf
des weges die menschen verloren die sie
eigentlich hätten ansprechen müssen und
die erreichst du auch in einer solchen
situation glaube ich nicht mit einer
anhäufung von information sondern mit
einer emotion die emotion habe ich
völlig vermisst und das war
interessanterweise der moment an dem ich
nie geglaubt hat dass ich mir nochmal
den söder zum kanzler wünschen würde der
hätte das nämlich begriffen und der kann
emotionen die er kann ob das sympathisch
ist etwas anderes aber er nimmt wie wie
seinerzeit strauss & co die leute mit in
ihrer begeisterung in ihrer
begeisterungsfähigkeit die botschaft
liegen dann oft verloren aber man sagt
ja den will ich das ist eine emotionale
entscheidung und ich habe
interessanterweise heute zum ersten mal
den scholz in aktion gesehen der war mir
immer so als als als rand politiker als
hamburger bürgermeister und spd mann
stehen die spd nicht wollte im system
ich habe mir gedacht wie kommt er dazu
er hat das in der tat nicht schlecht
gemacht weil er genau das getan hat was
ich befürchtet habe er hat nämlich in
schlaftabletten artiger art und weise
nichts falsch gemacht ich konnte ihm in
jeder beziehung folgen aber ich wünschte
mir eben er diese ausreise politiker hat
er auch die merkel hat uns ja auch in
diesen jahren entwöhnt was emotionen
betrifft die die die bei bei schröder
noch da waren dann in irgendeiner form
opfer star sympathisch und ich spielt
keine rolle aber zwischendurch basta
versteht jeder verstehen kinder wenn es
die eltern sagen dastehen die eltern
wenn es der opa sagt das sind emotionen
die frei werden die gehören für mich
verdammt noch mal zur politik und dazu
dass ich aufwache in meiner lethargie
ich bin heute aus der lethargie nicht
aufgehört weil ich keinen grund hat und
weil mich niemand geweckt hat klaus
natürlich jemand geweckt heute.de aber
mir ist mir ist noch mal zurück zum
boxkampf aufgefallen beim boxen hat ja
der der angreifer sozusagen immer nur
die chance den weltmeister zu schlagen
wenn der in ko schlägt wenn es
unentschieden aus gibt bleibt der
weltmeister weltmeister und das
interessante rollen spiel heute war
das ist der kanzler scholz ist gegen
zwei andere leute angetreten das war
also auf also durch die umfragen
natürlich vorgegeben war aber das ganze
rollenspiel in der runde sozusagen der
souveräne wir sagen langweilig aber der
souveräne kanzler wird von zwei anderen
unter feuer genommen mehr oder weniger
oder 20 minuten lang und ist souverän
lässt es abtropfen ich glaube dass olaf
scholz diese was ihnen bei den menschen
offensichtlich so populär macht in
diesen minuten und in dieser zeit jetzt
dieses m s haben wir souverän lässt sich
hier nicht sagt l und amtsinhaber genau
und ich habe nein gesagt eigentlich
betrug oder haben sie gar nicht so als
wäre schon bundes ich glaube ich man
könnte das sogar in den einzelnen szenen
nachweisen die alte theater regel den
könig machen immer die anderen wenn der
könig auf der bühne steht und alle
anderen machen so oder so dann ist
derjenige der könig an dem sich die
anderen abarbeiten und das war heute
olaf scholz oder vollzeit der könig
dieser runde und er geht auch als könig
ganz offensichtlich aus diesem studio
wieder raus für unsere zuschauer wir
warten noch auf die entscheidende
umfrage wer hat das ding gewonnen kommt
von infratest dimap werden wir hier
natürlich diskutieren sobald es da ist
lena du hast die ganze zeit als klaus
geredet hat so geguckt als wärst du bei
manchen sachen ganz anderer meinung wie
hat olaf scholz heute auf dich gewirkt
hat er gewirkt wie der bundeskanzler
oder der zukünftige bundeskanzler
einstimmig klaus tue ich stelle mir sehr
oft so bei einer sache bin ich klar
dagegen ich kann es hat überhaupt nicht
so gewirkt wie der kann's also der könig
mit seinen zwei hunden befeuern also
frau berbalk das sag ich war ja ganz
klar fand ich es weiß schon wie so ein
zukünftige koalition wo sie dann da will
ich muss noch mal sagen obwohl sie
plötzlich auf die uhrzeit von dem
hinweis das ist ein kampf jede minute
ist körperlich ja auch ein bisschen das
annalena baerbock im prinzip nur noch so
überweist änderungen aber nena hat rea
es war der könig mit seiner hilfe und
einen dagegen ankämpfen ich sage es
jetzt nicht
dagegen ankämpfen der faschingsprinz
[Musik]